30 seconds of snow goes so the song
playing right now is the Beatles golden
slumbers and that song is also used in
the animated anthropomorphize movie sync
so my question is how one minute and 31
seconds capture the imagination of
animators everywhere it's a nice song
for sure carry that weight is right
there look this is a perfectly fine
family film but this is George King
Miller this movie and the sequel
distracted that national treasure from
making Mad Max fury road for years and
I'm not forgiving it man yes I know he's
Australian and thus they're a national
treasure but I'm also claiming him frost
dammit let's get this out of the way
right up front the music license for
this movie which the right and holy gods
of the YouTube heavens would never let
me play much off is pure magic and joy
and puppies and rainbows and warms the
cockles of my tiny black heart take your
sin removal you damned happiness witches
and begone with you cockles remember way
back in 2006 when we actually had polar
ice hang justification also the fact
that I know it's Nicole Kidman singing a
Baratheon Marilyn Monroe version of kiss
one of princes most sensual songs is
making me uncomfortable at how much this
animated penguin movie is making body
parts other than my feet happy also also
print songs have been used to hook up a
million times before but not like this
kiss ain't an emotional ballad man it's
about straight up she literally just
sang the lines you don't need experience
to turn me out the word sex is so dirty
has to change it to egg also this is
preceded by like a million different pop
songs which means between the voice
talent the animation budget and the
amount they spent on the song rights by
my count this movie must have cost
seventy two billion dollars it's math
people why does everybody in penguin
town standing here Inconvenient heart
shapes stop and watch these two chord
each other shouldn't they still be all
horned up and trying desperately to find
their own musical mates also that snow
is way too white when you consider
penguins as a species have yet to invent
indoor plumbing in fact scientists have
said they can identify penguin colonies
from space based on the giant stains on
the ice true story his mom and dad met
in the you
way back where Asian the moms left for
the fishing season while the dad stayed
home to do egg time ah kind of like the
reverses of the shape of water and
inconvenient happy feet
I get the feeling this is a movie
created almost solely on the premise
that baby penguins are the cutest
carbon-based entity in the entire
universe not that I can blame them for
it but I can send them for it we didn't
make of that little wobbly in the knees
huh protagonist is born with a hindrance
that is mocked by his community who will
someday need that characteristic to save
them cliche you're doing there boy I
would be too if I came out of the womb
with full abilities to walk talk and
easily communicate with my community
what'd you do with your feet you thrall
Happy's brothers the great Guin does not
test us with a lean season why is Noah
going full Braveheart accent here Hugh
Jackman is doing some sort of Elvis
impersonation and Nicole Kidman is doing
her best Marilyn Monroe but on all these
penguins born raised and then never
leave this one community shouldn't they
all speak a very similar dielectric
she's not a little analog I'm gonna talk
you know a movie is hitting all the
relevant musical references when it
pulls out the Big Bopper
speaking of which pulling out the Big
Bopper is what my college go for not for
long if you keep calling them that today
we begin with a damn miss viola if this
is the most important lesson ever then
shouldn't you make sure your class is
fully attended in public schools where
it's not something that I can actually
teach then what was the point of this
class position goddamnit miss viola is
way too hyperbolic to be the teacher of
this elementary tonight that one I could
really get jiggy with that even in 2006
this was too dated of a reference that's
not even a tune is like really you're
gonna call out mumbles for his
syncopated heart tune when mere seconds
ago you were praising some kid for doing
Grandmaster Flash and either of them as
primarily melodic so what gives and
actually that's a scale not a song and
here I thought my music teacher was an
asshole the penguin without hot song is
hardly opinion at all heart reaming
these penguins doing anyway everyone's
just standing around like a dickhead
instead of hunting or gathering or doing
anything productive this is why you have
to make up stories about your heart
songs to make these assholes interesting
you want to meet the beautiful girls you
will do will make the egg
oh yes I'm having a hard time deciding
what I'm most disturbed by here that
this child penguin was just asked if he
wants to make the egg that his response
was a very hearty oh yes or that all
this is happening in a movie geared at
families with children I mean I guess
eggs ed classes have to start at some
point but I was hoping it would be at
least after the first mole as
artistically inclined as this penguin
colony is even if they've never seen
dancing before how would they not
immediately recognize it was a fun thing
that might go along very well with the
music they are already singing it's not
like the kid is making fart noises with
its wing Pitts
he just Gregory Hines himself down
that's no Bank like he'd been training
for years why'd you do an air flipper
boy that's flip sister flying boys
that's me hey this little boy and the
fish not with this attitude though right
just eat some humble pie the Penguins
tastes better if they're terrorized
beforehand is this penny wise and a V
informed they blowed me they tie me up
they strap me down they take this pointy
thing and they stick it out to me who's
doing what to who no I didn't mumbles
new boat I go it was there just a few
seconds ago and I was just starting to
enjoy his eleventh Doctor cosplay oh
never mind its back it's going to see
for the first time G's movie puts way
more emphasis on penguin education than
is necessary
they spent all that time in school just
to learn how to swim celebratory molting
okay so mumbles aloud on the fishing
trip even though he didn't graduate
that was the point of all the school
then also the movie plainly said only
the moms usually leave for the fishing
season and that was in the winter so why
are any of them going out on this
expedition grin and I'm no penguin
expert I'll leave that to Morgan Freeman
and Benedict Cumberbatch but penguins do
only have two eyes in the front right
because somehow this entire group of
them facing the ocean managed to get out
of the way as mumbles falls down this
slope this is delightful and all but are
none of these assholes hungry they're
here to catch fish right this doesn't
get an immediate flipper to the beak
summer of 69
donkey fish missionary to the South Pole
the hell movie I brought my kids to this
thing
mumbles survives this and this
graduation infatuation illumination did
Fat Joe really need to be in this movie
I mean they really could have recycled
Adam Sandler's Cajun man bit please tell
me they're not gonna play the entire
Live Aid sent everybody
leave Jesus Christ these bullies bully
so hard it's like they came directly
from a Stephen King novel Gloria wait
they straight up abandoned his ass like
everyone agreed that mumble was useless
to the group because he couldn't sing
and they left him out here to like die
ah burst the seal mom will clearly
attended the Prometheus School of
swimming away from things any thigh
robber but damn it why do penguins
always have to be the comic relief this
movie already has penguins thank you
coming tall boy what you've got
something better
yes he does like find his colony for one
but sure why not head off with
culturally appropriated Robin Williams
here to a party instead
you like to party I'd remove all the
sins if the next shot was of mobile
doing lines of snow off the moon's ass
[Music]
you guys are soft in the head okay geez
that escalated quickly
I guess screw these guys for politely
refusing to dance further your people
wanting something me
this goes on for some time look I know
we have to stretch this
fish-out-of-water story to
feature-length but it's already well
past that so do we really need this much
filler of the downhill shenanigans this
movie is so spectacularly gorgeous that
at times I wonder if it might actually
deserve that Oscar at one also I'm
pretty sure these assholes caused this
massive avalanche and not only do they
not care I'm pretty sure they're into it
does this have to do with anything in
this movie I'm starting to wonder if
I've wandered into a 2001 style
alternate dimension where the movie
about a misfit penguin with dance skills
becomes a meditation on the impact of
humanity honest way stood or overused in
this movie by the way something about
its performance as simple as I didn't
show more it's at this point in the
movie where you start wondering exactly
what dose of hallucinogens the writers
were using during the script phase
determining it was at least 13% too hot
I will retire now to my couch of
Perpetual Indulgence okay ladies I guess
we are adding group sex to the list of
things I have to explain to my kids
tonight he'll produce this thing Larry
Flynt nothing ceases oh you gotta do is
sing I thought it was the fishing season
right isn't that why mumbles cohort got
sent to the sea in the first place
dammit this should be a very simple
timeline to follow these four goons are
singing Bowie's demands I'll make love
to you for Gloria's affection but if she
likes their heart song which one does
she get wet not to mention that every
singing a heart song at everyone so is
this basically a key party turn him turn
around wow I guess Gloria wants to
reenact my regular Wednesday night so
everything's good now did mumble really
do anything different he's been dancing
for Gloria this entire fucking time but
this works from the spot and now we have
this uprising nobody's really thought it
could suddenly become webbed Footloose
without me noticing and movies wrong
fought on friends lead us into your easy
ways make it great again happy feet
can't cause a famine I think it comes
from outside way beyond the ice well
that's quite a leap considering all he
knows is it some bird claimed to be
abducted and there was a strange machine
the fell into the water I'm not sure how
mumbo connected the environmental doubts
to the food shortage bug message it's
got a message I guess if we are devout
sincere in our praise the fish will
return I guess Memphis is a big Joel
Steen fan just doesn't make any sense
script margin note accidentally gets
included in final draft the thing about
his neck it's way too tight what
Lovelace has been wearing this for a
presumably long-ass time so why is it
just now joking him I know he's getting
progressively fatter but that soft
plastic that would be expanding with his
neckline also doesn't he usually had a
harem around him did they all step out
for a smoke break at the exact same time
swim in and it just got caught around
your neck either mumble should be a
professional charade guesser or movie
needed to yada-yada us through this
quickly to get them where they need to
go I'm guessing it's that second thing
did he just run into the camera
capturing the shot does that mean that
this is an animated found footage you
know I really should keep my mouth shut
I'm pretty sure I just wrecked her
actively gave some studio exec the idea
for 2007 Surf's Up
dammit what are you doing here and more
importantly how are you doing here
seriously did Gloria find him when no
one in his original colony even knew
about Lovelace and even if she could
have gotten a Lovelace's place no one
was there to tell her about the game of
charades position that happened to point
him in this direction it's not you it's
me
I'm just not up for a serious
relationship right now I swear to God
this movie is 89 percent filler can we
skip this part at least the dance
sequences have better camerawork it's a
little Nana Tootsie for my taste
oh cool protagonist fight before the
climax of the movie cliche does this
mean we're almost done do they not
realize Lovelace is literally dying like
is it really that big of a deal to try
and remove the plastic even if it's
temporarily painful catchy a person is
little
why they've really been thing in that
pie
I'm down with saving the environment but
laying it on a bit thick here isn't
there a way to make the same point about
human and DIF without preaching it ass
like we're evil this movie makes the
Lorax look subtle no no my mopey movie
moment mostly moans morosely damn it
this movie is freaking gorgeous I
couldn't it also bother to be good hey
get your Paramount out of my Warner
Brothers house lovely it's not dead
already
he's been steadily choking for the last
several days so much so that he can't
talk walked across the blizzard
landscape and hang by this buoy and now
it's pretty much drowned
he's like the penguin version of
Rasputin these orcas deciding to
conveniently play with their food and
therefore free Lovelace is convenient of
course a massive ship comes through this
abandoned graveyard of a port in
Antarctica this very moment and it makes
zero noise until it's right on top of
mumbles team hey remember when this
movie was about mumbles and ability to
fit in because he liked to dance well
neither does this movie humble mumbo
bumbles and stumbles then tumbles and
fumbles through the propeller as it
rumbles but somehow doesn't get jumbled
or crumble and so I show bumble my
there's no way you didn't see all this
when he exited that tunnel about a
minute ago also is there some senior
waiting that he was unconscious all the
way until the moment of walking out here
surely there were already many
interactions with humans to get him
ready to be in this habitat right hang
on mumbo washed up and in Australia
that's hard enough to believe
considering its 2,500 goddamn miles away
from an architect but now movies saying
he's in Florida might even include this
dramatic planetary unzoom if it's gonna
confuse your narrative this much movie
what the hell here's an extra 20 cents
for all the geographical yada yada
where did all these people suddenly come
from if you give it a few minutes for
the word to get around the zoo sure as
many people might show up but we're this
many people already in the penguin
exhibit but somehow not already looking
at the Penguins I know this is supposed
to be a scene of emotional redemption
but I can't help thinking this feels
more like marky-mark jerking off for the
dude the truck toward the end of Boogie
Nights
and now mumbles yadda yadda this way
back home to what exactly are we
supposed to believe happened here that
the world found a dancing penguin and
instead of commercializing it or giving
it its own reality show
it took him back to Antarctica to let
him find his old stomping ground
everything cool here baby
you remember Seymour man what was with
Brittany Murphy hooking up with rappers
and movies so you're not I guess I never
heard the right song damn it movie there
is no way Gloria waited for him all this
time and this hotbed of sexual energy
it's much more likely she would have
gone full cast away by now and habit
but this former dentist why the hell did
the amigo stay here this is an emperor
penguin colony right aren't they trying
to kick these guys out before mumble
left where's pop what come on I'll show
you you better come take a look at this
cliche Wow Nicole Kidman and Hugh
Jackman in a musical reminds me that 9
and the greatest showmen are things that
exist I know you couldn't hear it likely
because they thought better and removed
it but the subtitles at this moment
clearly say wholly flock and I've
decided to send both this ridiculous
near swear and also not having the snow
balls to leave in it I think you better
dance now so the humans not feed the
Penguins if they didn't dance I know
this is a curiosity but if they flew all
the way to Antarctica don't you think
these assholes would just you know give
him some fish sure just a few seconds
ago they didn't even know how to dance
but now somehow they have the entire
routine choreographed are they trying to
tell us something so what's the problem
among other things we are messing with
their food chain we have got to do
something about it yes this is exactly
how humans would react to these
phenomena by inferring that animals were
communicating a very specific
environmental concern oh sweet baby
penguin Jesus and just like that the
climate change and mass extinction were
no more because a bunch of penguins went
to tap school don't ever say Hollywood
never offers real solutions dude I don't
care if they have one too Stanley Cups
in the last three years this is some
rampant over celebration
we'll know how our dinner I never saved
anything for the Sweetback hello chosen
trouble looks like we'll have to send
someone down Wow its purpose it
creativeness purpose it connects us
swept up by the great currents he was
carried endlessly across vast oceans the
sea was angry that day my friends the
couple has found one now the mother sees
her chick for the first time I'm a
particular kind of guy the kind of guy
who needs his own space so enormous it
feels all body it must escape you
explode so we're just done with phrasing
right that's not a thing anymore
[Music]
I'm lucky day I'm that middle-earth I'm
dusty bottoms are together we're all
free amigos